on va parler télé bien sûr dans un
instant andermatt ur il appelle à l
émission là comme je respecte les
spectateurs qui viennent de nous prendre
tout de suite j'ai un dossier sur cyril
hanouna
il a à faire un film avec nous je suis
mais c'était en 2006 je n'ai jamais
jamais et qu'on a coproduit avec jean
rachid ainsi mon affaire en galère une
autoproduction galère il n'a jamais vu
les roches et l'a jamais vu il n'a rien
vu donc là c'est juste pour vous il y
avait tout non comme un ben whishaw
on va nous ressortir tout le monde est
en gros comme ça c'est magnifique
alors si ces partis ttc jamais plus les
extraits je jouais quoi déjà dedans je
pense que l'ajout ni nurullah là bas les
gens rachètent des joueurs non chers
kaboul et sont peu son père lui mais un
ultimatum son père lui dit ben ça suffit
les conneries folle tu arrêtes de
racketter les merguez frites wright
arrête de racketter tout le monde dans
paris il faut que tu te maries mais le
problème arid amoureux de nine ou non le
problème c'est que c'est un problème
pour lui et mais pas pour d'autres c'est
il aime les garçons ah ouais un problème
pour son père c'est un problème
et toi toi tu es la petite [ __ ] déjà
rage
nous sommes encore là tout va bien c'est
un ami d'enfance je n'ai pas pu dire
quand et pas aux états unis onu russie
avant de traiter mais c'est bon j'ai
trouvé un distributeur est le petit ami
de jean g genre à chier j'ai jamais vu
ces images
regardez à la non c'est parce que c'est
un gros dossier tu prends des mers
technique turmo constituent des gages
fait-on
ce qui fait au bas d'une toque sur la
tête c'est toi qui l'avait ramené ce
bordel ambiant
mais pas sur le plateau mémoriser et
d'une phrase et d'une phrase qui est un
classique qui va rester dans le dans le
cinéma français grave et jean rachid et
rentrent avec le flanc comme ça tu dis
ok on arrête j'ai fait un couscous al
arabia tu as ça n'existe pas non non non
il ya un deuxième extrait un deuxième
la taille ou les lessives ou peu chagrin
d'amour c'est lui
et là tu vends le film bien combien
distributeurs là franchement appelé non
autorisée mais des buts sur ses rails on
a fait un contrôle c'est là on pas
jamais dans le vent tourner la page sur
le site ils obligés mois cyril hanouna
oui interprétant le personnage de ninon
dans le film la dernière passe jusque là
vous avez mimi nous donc je veux bien
oui on n'est pas d'accord c'est moi cdc
s'était coupé ou pas parce qu'ils ont
très bien et dans la dernière scène par
scène qui ressemble mais qui a gagné
l'eurovision
il faut que le film fait à y penser à
mon avis parce que mes budget qu'on
produit par jean rachid et j'atteste sur
l'honneur en présence de passy et d'un
million de téléspectateurs que je donne
les pleins pouvoirs à stomy bugzy en dvd
vod même en cassette vhs il a su
présents et à venir c'est vrai aux
prises par la présence et à utiliser mon
image gracieusement mais c'est fait
c'est fait si c'est bien sûr que c'est
fait
c
les affaires j'ai passé des coups de
coeur